bonjour jacqueline eustache brinio merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct sur rt france on a entendu le
ministre de la santé hier dévoiler cette
nouvelle mesure qui prendra effet à
partir du 2 janvier prochain un
couvre-feu avancé à 18 heures on a vu
quelques réactions dans le sujet
précédent le maire de nice lui c'en est
un est réjoui c'était ce qu'il voulait
imposer un couvre-feu plutôt que qu'en
pensez vous je crois qu'aujourd'hui on
doit faire face effectivement certaines
problématiques de cette épidémie et
cette pandémie dans des régions et on
voit bien depuis deux jours qu'un
certain nombre d'élus qui demande de
nouvelles mesures parce qu'ils sont
inquiets ce mois de janvier
donc ce couvre-feu est effectivement
peut-être une solution pour éviter une
catastrophe au mois de janvier est en
tout cas un confinement parce que je
crois que les français aujourd'hui
serait effectivement relativement
hostile 1re confinement et puis il y
aurait des conséquences économiques
encore plus grave parce que faut
reconnaître que aujourd'hui on parle
elle apprend des mimes et nous allons
avoir une année 2021 quand même
extrêmement compliqué au niveau
économique
donc voila moi je pense que évidemment
c'est toujours une atteinte à nos
libertés
ces couvre feu effectivement à 18 heures
après moi la question qui pour moi est
fondamental c'est cette campagne de
vaccination qui part aussi lentement je
me pose quand même des vraies questions
oui alors justement j'allais vous poser
la question est ce qu'on est en retard
une cinquantaine de personnes entre 50
et 70 d'ailleurs on n'a pas les chiffres
officiels des vaccinations en france
plus de 2 millions aux états unis et 800
me le royaume uni qui a commencé avant
l'allemagne qui a commencé en même temps
on est à 18000 ce chiffre de 60 disent à
peu près en france ça vous inquiète
c'est inquiétant il s'interroge sur
l'anticipation comme d'habitude et la
mise en place et la logistique
je crois que on a là la réalité de ce
qui se passe en france c'est à dire
probablement espèce de lourdeur étatique
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on a énormément
communiqué sur têt campagne de
vaccination qui est extrêmement
nécessaire vraiment enfin moi
personnellement je suis évidemment
favorable
et on a beaucoup communiqué nous mêmes
les élus les parlementaires les préfets
nous ont dit nous sommes prêts le 28
août et près 70 si on n'était pas dans
une pandémie aussi grave on aurait
presque envie de rire 70 personnes mais
à ce rythme là il va falloir deux ans
pour vacciner toute la france quoi on
nous avait bien donné un calendrier en
dix ans dès la fin décembre les ehpad
pas de problème le personnel soignant
pas de problème cuit après les personnes
qui vivent dans un établissement puis
après les plus fragiles pour arriver
jusqu'aux soixante cinq ans puis après
une grande campagne qui pourra concerner
tout le monde à partir du mois de mai
juin mais je pense qu'on n'y est pas on
n'en a pas là donc ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas anticipé et qu'on nous dise pas
qu'elle et brown de consentement gier on
savait qu'on allait lancer une campagne
de vaccination dans les ehpad fallait
juste y prendre un petit peu avant et
peut-être faire appel à des médecins
libéraux
peut-être faire appel à des médecins qui
sont tout à fait capables de vacciner
mais je pense qu'on a nous pas anticiper
et pas mis en place les bons moyens
humains pour avoir une campagne de
vaccination rapide et efficace
ça c'est un vrai souci quand même
beaucoup de grâce a effectivement
beaucoup de médecins généralistes disent
qu'il faut accélérer le pas olivier
verront hier a dit qu'il assumait
complètement le rythme le monsieur
vaccin d'ailleurs du gouvernement alain
fischer a dit que c'était bien d'aller
lentement écoutez le je ne suis pas sûr
qu'on puisse aller vraiment plus vite
tout d'abord il ya un certain nombre de
doses qui arrivent dans le pays
il faut donc cette organisation
logistique extrêmement complexe et donc
ceci explique qu'on ne puisse pas
vraiment les plus vite mais j'ajoute
mais je pense que c'est bien pour mike
pela plus vite car c'est bien d'aller
plus vite on ne comprend pas bien
pourquoi qu'en pensez vous c'est bien
qu'on n'avait pas pu vite mis au frigo
excusez moi mais c'est hallucinant dire
un truc pareil 70 personnes mais c'est
rien il ya des milliers de personnes à
vacciner et c'est bien mais ça ne veut
rien dire cette phrase je trouve ça même
excusez moi je vais mal et petits bleus
c'est irresponsable
on sait que cette campagne de
vaccination est nécessaire en
particulier rapidement dans les ehpad
parce que dans les ai pas les
conséquences elles sont dramatiques
voilà on sait très bien que dans les
ehpad et personnes fragiles peuvent
décider assez rapidement que la vie dans
les ehpad dès lors qu'il ya plus de
visites des familles elle est
catastrophique pour les personnes qui
sont des
orienté perdu bon et pour le personnel
aussi donc dire que c'est bien ne pas
aller vite c'est quand même être m la
santé je dirais de nos concitoyens en
danger vraiment donc arrêtons de donner
des justifications à tous donnons nous
les moyens
soyons un peu moins étatiques et faisons
confiance aux médecins libéraux aux
personnes qui sont là pour pouvoir
donner des solutions mais le problème
c'est que effectivement l'état à tout
centraliser sur les ars et que c'est
lourd voilà c'est très lourd je pense
que dans d'autres pays
l'organisation est moins lourde et moins
centralisée voilà je pense que c'est
juste cela l'une des explications est
celle en tout cas pour vous c'est
vraiment une question de logistique les
vaccins sont gars là en france on a on
peut même se poser la question du coup
un parent d'origine entendus jeudi pour
vous c'est vraiment une question de
logistique d'organisation et c'est à se
demander si les vaccins sont là bas on
nous dit que les vaccins sont là on lit
que dans chaque département il ya un
lieu sécurisé pour garder les les
vaccins à la température nécessaire donc
on nous dit qu'on a tous mais en tout
cas elle se passe rien d'eau sans nous
ment ce n'est pas efficace
moi je pense que là on n'est pas
efficace surtout qu'on n'est pas
efficacement l'eau 5
le gouvernement dit qu'il ne faut pas
confondre vitesse et précipitation alors
ils marchent sur les yeux parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de réticences en france à peu
près 60% mais on oublier les 40 % de
français qui ont sont prêts à servette
signer
on pourrait commencer par heure non bien
évidemment moi je suis persuadé que dans
les ehpad où les pertes les personnes
âgées ou leur famille sont tout à fait
favorables à l'utilisation dès lors que
les gens disent oui bah donnons nous les
moyens de vacciner tout de suite à ne
tendons pas je ne sais pas trop quelle
organisation lourdingue excusez moi
l'expression qui permettent d'avoir
simplement 70 personnes vaccinées depuis
le 28 mai c'est juste on a envie dry
peut-être presque ont envie de pleurer
vraiment parce qu'à ce rythme là on
n'est pas sortir vraiment alors le
rythme l'objectif affiché en tout cas
c'est un million de personnes vaccinées
d'ici à fin janvier ça fait quinze
minutes par jour vous y croyez bassir
que vu le chiffre qu'on a aujourd'hui je
ne crois pas du tout alors soit l'état
remet en cause complètement cessé ses
moyens humains et logistiques pour y
arriver mais je veux dire à ce rythme
leurs débats pré y arriver vraiment et
c'est très inquiétant parce qu'à la fois
on sait très bien qu'on a des risques
dans une épidémie qui repas
à après les fêtes on sait très bien que
le confinement
tout le monde souhaite l'éviter et moi
la première donc donnons nous les moyens
et arrêtons cette espèce de lourdeur
permanente qui permettent de se faire de
ben on est dans une espèce
d'autosatisfaction en trouvant des mots
stupides ne pas confondre vie cette
vitesse et précipitation on est juste
face à une pandémie et la pandémie elle
elle sait ce que c'est la vitesse et la
précipitation
elle c'est est ce que pour vous
l'exécutif devrait montrer l'exemple en
se faisant vacciner comme l'ont fait
d'ailleurs d'autres chefs d'état
bah oui pourquoi pas enfin voila c'est
donner l'exemple c'est toujours une
bonne chose
moi si on demandait levac si demain
j'irai quoi enfin je veux dire j'attends
mon tour parce qu'il ya des gens qui
sont effectivement prioritaire et c'est
l'essentiel
mais si on devait nous demander un doute
de de montrer l'exemple marocain aucun
souci pour le faire est là on va
paraître la stratégie mise en place pour
cette fin d'année gérald darmanin qui a
montré les muscles pour le nouvel-an
immo glisse cent mille policiers en
garde et il a envoyé une directive aux
préfets cent mille policiers et
gendarmes seront exceptionnellement
mobilisés
la priorité doit être donnée ces
prochains jours à la lutte contre les
rassemblements non autorisés et les
phénomènes de violences urbaines dans
les centres villes les quartiers les
zones sensibles les plus sujets à ces
phénomènes est ce que c'est la bonne
méthode selon vous alors il est évident
que il faut des moyens humains physique
dans les villes partout pour éviter les
rassemblements pour éviter les
traditionnelles entre guillemets fête du
31 voitures brûlées voilà hervé niel
c'est les gens qui feraient des fêtes à
plus de 6 ou ruth mais honnêtement
intervenir chez les gens je pense que ça
c'est pas ça le sujet c'est surtout
protéger l'espace public de débordements
qui peuvent avoir lieu parce qu'il ya
des risques ya un vrai risque de
débordement comment on va effectivement
empêché les attroupements dans l'espace
public
alors les fait évidemment peut-être des
gens feront d'éditer des dérivants il ya
huit au lieu de six jean louis lafon
sont les jeunes qui vont être visé ce
sont les jeunes qui vont être libérés
mais oui oui mais je dire nous n'aurons
pas franchement il faut pas se mentir je
pense que l'état n'a pas les moyens
humains et les policiers ne pourront pas
aller vérifier chez chacun
nous si on écarte si on est 200 et 600
et 8 voilà l'idée c'est de faire
appliquer le couvre-feu faire en sorte
qu'ils aient personnes dans les rues et
faire en sorte que dans les lieux
repérés effectivement la police puisse
intervenir
mais bon moi je suis un peu inquiète sur
cette soirée du 31
je ne suis pas sûr que dans certains
quartiers dans certaines villes il n'y
ait pas des tentatives de provocation
parce que de l'ordre notamment comme
tous les comme tous les révélations ils
ont comme tous les ans 31
on est content quand on se dit il y a
moins de voitures brûlées que l'année
d'avant et puis on finit par croire les
chiffres depuis deux ans n'a pu les
chiffres des voitures brûlées le 31 donc
j'imagine que dans ces quartiers je ne
suis pas sûr que le couvre-feu soit
respecté au doigt et à la lettre voilà
et donc ça ça ça va être une vraie
difficulté le 31 ça c'est évident on
l'aura on n'a plus le temps à la règle
non satisfaits en disant c'est mieux que
l'année dernière voilà merci beaucoup on
en reparlera l'année prochaine
jacqueline eustache brinio merci d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france